Japan's high-speed trains the Shinkansen
can reach speeds of up to 320 kilometers
an hour they connect the country's
largest cities Japan has much to offer
in terms of modern infrastructure but
for the Olympic Games in 2020 Tokyo is
investing even more in cutting-edge
technology participants are discussing
future visions and impulses in the
athletic world here at the World Forum
on sport and culture it's being hosted
by the Japanese government and the World
Economic Forum in Geneva I think the
role of talking 2020 is to show a
demonstrate what technology can play so
that other city can learn from the same
lesson it could be a failure it could be
a successful case both will be a big big
resource for other cities in the future
what role do sports play in the city
today and how will it look in the future
these are questions asked during a
lively debate sponsored by Deutsche
Welle and the World Economic Forum in
Tokyo when employers invest in an active
workforce they see huge benefits as it
relates to reduction in cost of health
care premiums Bell see much more
innovation much more productivity
basically they work for workforce will
be working for them much more
productively but the electronic games
that are so loved in Japan don't count
as sufficient physical activity even if
there are whole neighborhoods in Tokyo
where young people are dedicated to
nothing else